val verde county commissioner bo
nettleton is leading the effort to join
forces with his fellow border
communities he joins us right now from
del rio texas beau good morning to you
good morning how are y'all doing today
we're doing okay we're doing better than
you are you've got a you've got a crisis
on your hands although the
administration won't call it that one of
the things the federal government is
supposed to do is it's supposed to
provide the national defense
is the fact that they are not enforcing
our southern border isn't that a
violation
are they just letting people in isn't
this a national security problem
this is a huge national security problem
i mean we have people crossing this
border and we've heard numbers of this
group up to 20 000 and we've had
thousands before this
and then that doesn't even include the
fact that while our immigration officers
and dps and everybody's busy dealing
with these large crowds we still have
hundreds and hundreds and thousands of
people going around these communities
out through these rural areas
with drugs and smuggling and and all
kinds of other stuff and and we don't
even know some countries that they're
coming from not including all the
diseases that are coming with covid and
everything else sure so explain how it
works there in your county you know
because we see all these images like all
the people under the the bridge in del
rio you know they were looking for the
nearest border patrol person that they
could surrender to to be put into the
system
so is that how it generally works
they're looking for somebody from border
patrol or are we talking about a lot of
godaways who do not want to encounter
them because they've got drugs or
heavens to betsy who knows what
well you have two different sets of
groups you have this group which is
mostly made up of haitians and
venezuelans that are just looking for a
border patrolman to give up so they can
be allowed into the country and then you
have the other groups that are out there
that are that don't want to be caught
because they're hauling drugs you know
fentanyl and different types of things
and and human trafficking and and god
knows what else is going on out there uh
and these border patrol men are so tied
up with these large groups trying to
process them and deal with them they
don't have time to be out in the field
to deal with the other issues sure so
because the federal government will not
you know keep our southern border strong
the migrants are coming into your county
i would imagine that is really sapping
your community services you know if they
park in your county for a while they're
going to need stuff
no it is i mean we have you know border
patrol picks up groups and then they
release them into our communities and
and our ngo has to deal with it and
we're a small community this county is
about 49 000 people
uh we don't have the transportation
infrastructure to move people out of
here like you see in the larger cities
so people will get stuck here waiting
days and days and days for a bus to be
able to to to leave the community and go
wherever it is that they're headed
and it puts a big burden you know as of
right now i think our county has spent
probably over four hundred thousand
dollars dealing with this issue which
doesn't seem like a lot of money to a
lot of people when you're talking about
a community of this size four hundred
thousand dollars is a lot of money that
doesn't include what the hospital has
spent on treatment and other issues we
had 11 babies born during this incident
numerous cases of covid and those types
of things and it puts a big strain on it
you know thankfully the state sent some
people to help well let's hope the bite
administration cut you guys a check
because they owe you because they're not
enforcing the laws bo thank you very
much for joining us today from down in
texas